[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde là où parler d'un sujet
problématique
faut-il avoir peur du patriotisme
la patrie quel mot noble généreux
affectif la patrie c'est ce qu'on aime
pouvait dire l'historien français denis
fustel de coulanges dès que l'on
prononce le mot de patriotisme le kes le
consensus et questionner avec
bienveillance mais également de la
méfiance comme s'il y avait une
injonction à la fierté nationale a
épousé toutes les pages d'un récit
national forcément contrasté parce que
l'histoire d'un pays n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille et la france des
monarchies à la révolution et à la
république ne fut pas économe de
changements institutionnels
aujourd'hui probablement par souci de
faire ou de refaire cohésion nationale
et sociale de protéger notre culture et
nos modes de vie de soutenir la
concurrence industrielle et commerciale
ainsi que financières voilà que
l'ensemble de l'échiquier politique fait
assaut de patriotisme comme s'il y avait
péril en la demeure nation nous allons
en parler avec mes invités que je vous
présente bernard cazeneuve vous êtes
avocat vous avez été ancien premier
ministre laetitia strauss bonnart vous
êtes journaliste au point et céistes
louis gallois vous êtes industriel
armand laferrère directeur de société
[Musique]
alors commençons par un souci de
clarification et sur ce point romain
gary paraphrase le général de gaulle
pour qui le patriotisme c'est aimer la
france le nationalisme c'est détester
celui des autres pouvez vous nous donner
votre sentiment sur deux points nous
parlerons plus tard du contenu et du
sens du patriotisme mais à votre avis
bernard cazeneuve faut-il aimer son pays
et pour ce faire faute il se
débarrassait du nationalisme je pense
que on doit absolument aimait son pays
et pas simplement quand on est appelé à
le gouverner quand on y vit comme
citoyen l'amour de son pays est aussi
une manière d'altérité à l'égard des
autres qui vivent à l'intérieur des
mêmes frontières qui peuvent être
différents mais auquel on s'assimile en
raison de la communauté de valeurs
du sentiment que nous avons une histoire
commune partagée et aussi de la
conscience que nous pouvons avoir d'un
destin qui nous est commun donc oui il
faut aimer
absolument son pays aimer sa patrie
il faut aussi aimer la nation on va en
parler dans le détail va du tout on ti
nomique les deux concepts ne se
recouvrent pas totalement mais il faut
éco l'un à l'autre ce dont il faut se
méfier en revanche c'est du nationalisme
françois mitterrand avait dit à
l'occasion d'un grand discours prononcé
devant le parlement européen si je me
souviens bien le nationalisme c'est la
guerre et ils
penser à des moments funestes notre
histoire où l'embrasement nationaliste
dans la détestation parfois des autres
peuples avaient conduit aux pires
violences alors est ce que vous aimez la
france laetitia 11 bonnart mais bien sûr
que j'aime la france donc j'ai écrit un
livre sur le sujet donc qui ça montre
que je laime quand même un petit peu et
puis je suis revenu en france aussi
après sept ans passés en grande bretagne
donc c'est aussi un signe pour moi en
tout cas c'était un signe personnel que
mon pays ma plaie d'un point de vue plus
général je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que vous venez de dire bernard
cazeneuve et j'ajouterais qu'au delà de
l'amour il ya un sentiment qui est
important qu'ils aient la gratitude
c'est à dire que quand on est quelque
part
de la naissance on arrive dans un lieu
qui nous précèdent parler de soi mais
aussi par les valeurs on doit des choses
à cette communauté politique elle nous
offre une protection et des droits et en
échange on lui doit pas seulement de
respecter ses lois ça c'est le minimum
on va rentrer dans le détail lafarge 1,6
sur ce terme ou la loyauté auxerre
réciprocité avec gratitude c'est ce que
vous éprouvez armand laferrère la
réciprocité oui pour introduire un peu
de débats je ne suis pas sûr que nous
soyons encore à une époque où la
distinction que fait romain gary et
qu'on fait tant d'autres soit si
importante que ça pendant très longtemps
on sentait d'une part que l'amour du
pays d'abord de la tradition dont on
vient de la terre dont on vient est
important et d'autre part il y avait ce
reproche le nationalisme a causé les
guerres oui nationalisme a causé des
guerres beaucoup d'autres choses ont
causé les guerres c'est dire commence à
s'éloigner les deux notions sont quand
même finalement très proche celle de
nation et celle de patrice romain gary
avait choisi la france s'était pas la
terre de ses pères dont ne s'était pas
sa patrie c'était sa nation est
finalement peut-être faut-il arrêter de
diaboliser l'un pour favoriser l'autre
et dire que l'un et l'autre finalement
sont très proches et sont des sentiments
assez naturel et vous vous situez louis
gallois amour de la france inconsidérés
vous donnez eu
les réseaux qui m'ont conduit ce
patriotisme
j'ai passé deux ans japon faisait passer
sept en grande-bretagne moi j'ai passé
deux ans japon et j'ai appris à aimer
mon pays et au japon
non pas que j'ai détesté les japonais
j'ai adoré mon séjour japon j'ai le plus
grand respect pour les japonais mais
j'ai découvert ce que ce qui ma tâche et
à mon pays et parlement sortes de 2,2
d'atmosphère d'ambiance que je ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs et j'ai
compris que j'étais indéfectiblement
attachée à mon pays et je voudrais dire
un mot c'est que derrière cet amour du
pays il ya d'autres choses et il ya ce
sentiment d'appartenance
et ya l'idée du dévouement qui rejoint
un petit peu votre idée qui égratigne la
gratitude la gratitude ça entraîne une
réponse et l'idée du dévouement
dévouement se veut pas dire qu'on est
tous prêts à sauter sur kolwezi pour
défendre d'autres pays on va rentrer
dans le détail mais je parle en a retenu
était forte là dedans et c'est une des
choses qui alors qui m'attache on va
aller d un père marc cazenave on va
rentrer dans le détail je vais vous
faire une libération à la prévert et
vous allez me dire ce que vous gardez ce
que vous retranchez ou ce que vous
ajoutez le patriotisme soutenir l'équipe
de france quel que soit le sport
promouvoir le made in france par les
français
alors que l'académie française s'insurge
contre l' usage du franglais
défendre et même se sacrifier pour la
patrie au cours d'une guerre vibrer à
l'unisson de la marseillaise accepté
tous nos héritages lumière révolution
monarchie république prendra sin dans un
territoire
participé au mouvement social et à la
vie commune selon l'expression d'ernest
renan qu'est-ce que vous gardez
qu'est-ce que vous retrancher et
qu'est-ce que vous ajoutez alors moi
j'ai pas envie de retrancher quoi que ce
soit parce que ça d'accord avec la 10
suis d'accord avec notre inventaire à la
prévert qui me paraît comporter un
ensemble de deux principes de propos
d'attachement auquel je souscris
volontiers j'ajouterai un élément c'est
que head patriotes en france et avoir
conscience que la patrie porte des
valeurs qui la transcende une dimension
d'universalisme dans le projet français
dans ce que la france porte en héritage
de principes et de valeurs
qui très souvent dans l'histoire a
conduit la france à tenir aux peuples du
monde le discours que les peuples du
monde avait appris et medel pour
reprendre l'expression de grosses
habitants donc la patrie quand on a cet
attachement à travers l'ensemble des
exemples que vous des données ne peut
pas conduire un recroquevillement sur
elle même et de ce point de vue là je
partage pas puisque vous avez très
aimablement dans ces débats ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le fait que
les deux notions se recoupent dans les
deux notions ne se recoupent pas on est
dans un débat à l'occasion de cette
élection présidentielle où on voit un
certain nombre d'acteurs politiques qui
font grand bruit et qui disent aimer la
france et vouloir la restituer dans dans
sa grande histoire dans sa grandeur et
qui ont une relecture des faits de
l'histoire que notre pays a pu traverser
qui est très très très très loin d'être
conforme à ce que l'ambition universel
dont je parlais et qui est très loin
d'ailleurs d'être conforme à ce que
furent les faits de l'histoire dans leur
réalité et une certaine conception de la
nation reproduit y est sûre elle même
hostile aux autres peut conduire à
donner de la patrie qu'on dit aimer une
bien piètre image je vais on va rentrer
dans ce débat précisément mais sur le
l'inventaire à la prévert qu'est-ce que
vous rajoutez un louis gallois ou vous
retranchez je me pose la question de la
langue moi je suis très attaché aux
français et je soutiens l'académie
française dans ses propos de défense
deux françaises il ya des pays qui
vivait plusieurs langues qui sont des
pays où la patrie a un sens la suisse
je ne suis pas la belgique parce que
c'est particulier mais la suisse est un
pays c'est une pays où les suisses sont
des patriotes il le montre tous les
jours ils ont quatre langues donc je
pense que la langue n'est pas le seul
élément est la culture plus plus la
culture que la longueur
de la patrie une langue vernaculaire qui
est proche de quelques fois de la langue
maternelle qui n'est pas forcément la
langue du pays mais on peut parler
plusieurs langues mais en tout en
défendant la langue les suisses n'ont
pas de local oculaire les suisses n'ont
pas de langue vernaculaire mais le
problème auquel on est confronté et je
rejoue ans à l'académie française c'est
que ce n'est pas la langue de
shakespeare que l'on substitue l oms est
une espèce de rétablir improbable avec
un anglais mal parler qui vient percuter
un français columbia et puis sur le
lenglen c'est une langue importés en
fait en suisse sont des langues
organique organiquement suisse et mg
alors on va pas faire un débat
linguistique qu'est-ce que vous rajouter
ou retranchés sur l'inventaire du
patriotisme il ya un aspect problème
oyonnax qui met ça c'est personnel
l'équipe de france est complètement égal
mes voeux pour pour parler de la liste
des choses un peu plus lié aux alliés
des valeurs il y en a une qui est quand
même intéressante parce que pas
complètement fausse mais à mon avis mal
exprimé c'est de dire on accepte on est
l'héritage de l'ensemble de notre
histoire oui j'accepte je suis les
richesses l'ensemble de notre histoire
j'accepte que les antidreyfusards était
français que les pétainistes et les
français et c'est le fait d'accepter que
j'en suis l'héritier ne signifie pas que
je n'ai pas envie de leur casser la
gueule jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc oui nous
sommes les héritiers d'un ensemble de
choses ça ne veut pas dire que nous
respectons tout autant tout ce dont nous
sommes issus alors on a parlé de
dissonance
avec le mouvement des gilets jaunes la
france a connu une forme de rébellion
populaire on attribuer cela
géographiquement des fractures
territoriales historiquement à un
ressentiment populiste aujourd'hui près
de 40% de l'électorat se situe dans
cette charnière
identitaire est ce que cela ne montre
pas un patriotisme en désuétude pour
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'abord je n'ai pas répondu à la liste
oui et alors sur la liste j'aurais voulu
juste dire deux choses je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit sur l'héritage en fait on peut
très bien se sentir complètement
français et en même temps regarder des
épisodes
de notre histoire avec distance avec
scepticisme avec rigueur et ça je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord en tout
cas les gens modérés sont d'accord avec
cette idée en france près de 40% de
l'électorat qui se situe sur cette
frange
populiste extrémiste et cetera est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un problème de
patriotisme avec ça alors il ya deux
choses d'abord vous citez 40% de
français qui sont attirés par ces idées
dans ses idées il n'y a pas que du
patriotisme il ya plein d'autres choses
il ya des tensions sociales il ya un
désir de représentation politique donc
jeu on peut pas réduire ça à 40 % de
français qui serait hyper patriotes ou
nationalistes versus 60% qui serait
cosmopolite ça c'est la première chose
ensuite je pense qu'on assiste en partie
à une espèce de sur réaction
nationaliste parce que certains thèmes
patriotique n'ont pas été discutée
pendant très longtemps et c'est pas
seulement pendant cinq ans peut-être
depuis 30 40 ans parlons évidemment de
l'immigration on a toujours eu du mal à
avoir une discussion actuelle c'est à
dire combien on veut d'immigration
combien on peut accueillir avec quels
moyens et il ya des grandes divergences
dans notre pays sur disons le le seuils
d'immigration idéal et beaucoup de gens
ont été très facilement traiter de
raciste parce qu'il voulait simplement
en discuter le résultat c'est que
plusieurs années plus tard voilà on a
une espèce de sur réaction complètement
exagérée qui si on avait traité le
problème peut-être aurait été deux ou
trois pourcent de la population donc moi
je l'interprète comme ça
[Musique]
michelez tout comme renault ou braudel
exclut la race de la fécondation de la
patrie comme de la nation
interrogeons nous sur l'héritage
idéologique du patriotisme
quel est il finalement cet héritage et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce qui se
réfère à la race pour défendre leur
patriotisme est ce que vous diriez
bernard cazeneuve que ce sont des anti
patriote
je pense qu'il faut pour répondre à
cette question essayer de
reconstituer ce qui a été le processus
de construction possible historique de
construction de la nation en france et
du sentiment affectif
politique de relation de la relation de
chaque citoyen à la nation on est dans
un pays où l'état pour exister à la
nation
la nation s'est incarné dans l'état et
où la république apporte à la nation à
l'état un creuset de valeur dans lequel
le plus grand nombre c'est reconnu
qu'elles étaient ses valeurs ses valeurs
nous dicter que ce qui nous permettait
d'être dans l'unité et l'indivisibilité
de la nation était plus fort que ce qui
pouvait nous distinguer les uns des
autres et que ce qui nous permettait de
vivre dans une relation d'altérité à
l'autre c'était notre essence
fondamentalement humaine c'était ça qui
forme et la pensée universelle donc le
concept de race de prévalence de la
religion dans un pays de surcroît où la
laïcité a pris une
importance particulière n'existe pas
dans la pensée républicaine et dans la
pensée française comme un élément
structurant de la constitution de la
nation et à chaque fois que ce concept
est réapparu c'est généralement qu'on
s'éloignait de la république qu'on
s'éloigne et de l'amour de la patrie
regarder à travers le prisme des valeurs
républicaines pour introduire dans la
nation les creuser de la division c'est
votre avis louis gallois oui
certainement nous on exclut la race de
là la
rappelle que
indexation de droits de l'homme la race
n'est pas considéré comme un élément qui
peut diviser et on voit bien que la
révolution française a porté l'idée de
patrie ou parler de la patrie en danger
les hôtels de la patrie aux grands
hommes la patrie reconnaissante et c'est
la porte la patrie était porté par la
révolution qui était une révolution qui
est justement à lui effacé les races
ensuite les choses ont été plus
compliquées
la grosso modo la patrie a été porté par
les républicains jusqu'à la fin du 19e
et à la fin du 19ème avec la menace
allemande
on a vu apparaître
des dérives nationalistes avec la montée
de maurras mort astiz et vous les
républicains vous aurez à choisir entre
la entre la république et la patrie vous
pouvez pas être à la fois républicain et
patriote donc puis à hull à faire de
plus la feb réfugiés qui est absolument
clé dans cet arg sa fabrique dreyfus les
dreyfusards se réclamer de patriotes
heureusement il y avait peu guy de
l'autre côté qui était oui
malheureusement
louis gallois la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui en france est ce qu'il y a
un récit national ou deux récits
nationaux est ce qu'il ya un récit
national qui passe par clemenceau de
gaulle mendès-france et un récit
national qui passerait par bainville
maurras pétain et zemmour bien que ce
soit pas de même niveau que vous pensez
vous avez là c'est intéressant est ce
qu'on n'a pas de récit nationaux
aujourd'hui armand laferrère le seul
récit national qui compte c'est celui
qui admettent les deux co existent et
sont en conflits réguliers pas toujours
dans la résistance on a vu des
maurrassien et les communistes les uns à
côté des autres et chez vichy des
socialistes et des mauriciens aussi les
uns à côté des autres donc le débat
n'est pas toujours celui là et dans
certains cas cette tradition qui en est
fait dans l'ensemble s'engueulent à
juste titre peuvent se trouver du même
côté d'une autre division oui laetitia
strasbourg assure c'est quand même qu'on
peut faire une distinction entre les
faits et les valeurs c'est-à-dire qu'on
connaît les faits historiques et ces
personnes font partie de notre histoire
et ses courants en font partie ensuite
en termes de valeur on peut avoir ses
préférences personnellement j'ai une
préférence pour la politique de
l'honneur et j'estime que le patriotisme
c'est plutôt la politique de l'honneur
que la politique de l'intérêt et les
personnes que vous citez maurras et
d'autres représente pour moi plutôt un
patriotisme est plutôt même un
nationalisme de l'intérêt est à mon avis
c'est une distinction d'ailleurs qu'il
fonctionne toujours aujourd'hui
finalement chez eric zemmour c'est ça
qu'on retrouve c'est un nationalisme de
l'intérêt l'intérêt de la france passe
avant tout même avant son honneur alors
que je pense que le bon patriotisme
c'est un patriotisme de l'ona oui oui la
loi je viens d'un village neuf je suis
là excusez moi un peu réservé sur
distinction parce que
la france
a atterré à défendre ce qui fait son
honneur et à chaque fois qu'elle cesse
de défendre ce qui
correspond à ce que c'est complètement
des caissons d'honneur dans son long de
son histoire à ce moment là elle cesse
d'être elle-même et que bien entendu que
les deux courants coexistent dans
l'histoire de france bien entendu qu'il
ya eu ici à maurras et il ya la
résistance il ya des courants politiques
et idéologiques très différents il ya
même parfois certains qui appartient à
l'un de ces courants qui au moment où
l'histoire se dénoue viennent au secours
des premiers qui se sont trompés pour
essayer de les sauver moi je travaille
en ce moment sur mauriac j'ai été très
frappée de voir la manière dont mauriac
qui avait été insulté traîné dans la
boue par une grande partie de ceux qui
avaient appartenu au courant maurrassien
ou qui avait écrit dans les journaux
d'extrême droite de l'époque gringoire
je suis partout et cetera ont été
rachetés par lui il a essayé de les
sauver pour nom de la conception qu'il
avait delà du christianisme la
possibilité d hab d'être rachetée de cet
état je ne m'attarde pas sur ce sujet
mais c'est pour montrer l'extrême
complexité y compris des réactions
humaines individuelles peut y avoir face
à ces courants de l'histoire en revanche
la france républicaine elle
elle est articulée un certain nombre de
valeurs peut nier qu'il donna
identitaire aujourd'hui je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord avec l'idée que c'est
complexe parce que la force de ses
complexes il ya plus il ya plus de via
pull frontières succès les choses
deviennent floues il ya deux courants
que vous avez très bien illustré il ya
un courant nationaliste courant
patriotique le courant nationaliste et
celui qui part de barrès plongé de
barrès maurras et assez curieusement ce
mouvement nationaliste va aller vers
pétain
et et zemmour et s'inscrit là dedans
d'ailleurs
le dit pratiquement et puis vous avez un
courant qui est un courant que
j'appellerais républicain mais en plus
patriote qui va aller de clemenceau à
jaurès et qui sera repris par la
résistance la résistance elle et
patriotique lé patriotique elle donne
c'est assez curieux de voir les
nationalistes alors du côté de la
collaboration
et
les patriots incarné par l'arrêt à
londres il y avait aussi des monarchies
mais on peut toujours prendre des cas
particuliers mais ces cas particuliers
c'est pas passionnant ce qui est ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir comment
les mouvements d'idées sont allés armand
laferrère est pas d'accord n'auraient
pas du tout pas du tout il y avait il y
avait énormément de socialistes et les
filles avaient énormément de maurrassien
dans la résistance c'est effectivement
pas cette division là qui a joué c'est
une autre division ah non moi je ne suis
pas d'accord et
danser dans cette condition là le fait
que c'est d'eux que les deux camps au
moment au moment de vérité c'est un
roman où effectivement défend la france
on la donne aux allemands c'est quand
même fondamental ça n'est pas cette
division là qui joue c'est quelque chose
de plus fondamental de plus profond et
est tout à fait important pour répondre
aussi à votre question emile malet oui
ces deux traditions font partie de
l'histoire de france oui la plupart du
temps elles sont jeunes mais oui la
france n est pas les dreyfusards ce
n'est pas les antidreyfusards c'est le
fait que les deux co existent à
l'intérieur
mais vous êtes en désaccord vous vous
considérez qu'il peut y avoir un
patriotisme à l'extrême droite et que
louis gallois considère qu'il n'y a pas
de paris considère que les deux notions
était opposé à tort qu'elles sont pas
exactement identique mais quand des
faits un patriote d'extrême droite est
un patriote
sa propre patrie ça n'est plus du jeu on
va écouter points de divergence très
important
avec vous sur ce sujet le fait qu'ils
aient eu des socialistes qui étaient à
vichy des radicaux et des terres est une
réalité historique
mais je n'en déduis parce que vous en
déduisez vous même parce que lorsqu'il a
fallu choisir un moment tragique de
l'histoire de notre pays
quelle était la manière de sauver son
honneur au nom d'une idée qu'on se
faisait de la patrie y en a qui ont fait
le bon choix qui sont parties à londres
et qu'ils ont dit nous voulons nous
voulons pas que la france c'est cela
d'ailleurs la formule du général de
gaulle qui est très belle c'était celui
qui aime la france c'est à dire la
patrie et celui qui veut que la france
continue et c'est en vertu de cette
volonté qui était la sienne de voir la
france continue et qu'il est parti à
londres face à ceux majorité à l'époque
qui était prêt à la faire cesser dans la
compromission la plus grande et donc à
un moment donné il y à des hommes dans
l'histoire quelle que soit leur
sensibilité
socialiste communisme de droite mais
résistants et patriotes qui décide de
s'engager dans la résistance et de
rejoindre le général de gaulle donc je
partageais c'est votre sentiment que
tout n'est pas dans tous que les
courants ont existé dans l'histoire de
france mais qu'à un moment donné il ya
eu des sommes qu'ils avaient avec le
pays une relation suffisamment
tellurique pour ne pas accepter
l'égarement de tous rarement la balle et
on dit la même chose que ces mini seul
que j'ai dit c'est que la distinction
importante c'est celle là effectivement
simplement celle là ne correspond pas à
l'opposition des traditions qui a été
dit est il est défini avant ça n'est pas
cette distinction de la qui a joué en
effet entre un résistant et un
pétainiste qui a toute la différence du
monde en revanche ya un p tit nice
maurrassien pettini socialiste il ya un
résistant maurrassien avoir un résistant
socialiste est donc là la vraie
différence qui est apparue là n'est pas
celle que tout tatler et me l'a présenté
comme étant la cause dix ans deux choses
totalement différentes non non mais
notre défense
vous me semblez quand même assez assez
d'accord moi ce que je trouve surtout
intéressant c'est à quel point
aujourd'hui on est obligé de reparler
le fait qu'ils aient une distinction
entre ces deux courants on est d'accord
droit autorise que je ne l'aimais pas
sur un pied d'alerté doit non plus mais
ce que je trouve assez inquiétant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on en parle à nouveau et
ils sont à nouveau présents et vivaces
on n'aurait jamais pensé ya vingt ans
qu'on aurait pu alors ils potter on va
aller plus loin sur ce sujet là certains
reprochent à la mondialisation au
multiculturalisme vaut qu'ils menacent
eux nouveau
ce nouveau mode de société de défaire le
patriotisme en s'en prenant à l'ordre à
l'autorité et aux traditions
est-ce que vous pensez que ces
mouvements contribuer à déconstruire le
patriotisme laetitia alors pour
commencer j'aimerais établir une
distinction que j'ai vraiment éprouver
concrètement puisque j'ai vécu comme je
voulais 17 ans en angleterre et que je
peux vous témoigner que l'angleterre et
les états unis que je connais un petit
peu sont vraiment différent de la france
aujourd'hui il y à des mouvements
multiculturaliste ewoks si l'on veut
dans ces pays la france est vraiment
très loin de ressembler pour l'instant
aux états unis ou à l'angleterre donc je
suis un petit peu préoccupé aussi
d'entendre que voilà ça y est on vit on
vit dans le monde multiculturel anglo
saxons c'est vraiment faux enfin
j'essaie de l'expliquer le développer
dans mon livre c'est pour ça qu'à mon
avis on si on surestime la menace et on
surestime oui les dangers que l'on que
l'on est en train de courir mais
l'assaut de minorités c'est la
destruction de l'humain c'est la
première chose oui la deuxième chose
c'est que en effet je ne pense pas
qu'une société puisse accepter un niveau
trop élevé de diversité culturelle quand
il n'y a pas volonté de partager une
culture commune et j'en reviens à l'idée
que je développais au début qui est
cette idée de gratitude quand il n'ya
pas de gratitude comme une led envie de
partager pas forcément toute l'histoire
mais une partie de l'histoire et surtout
la politique quotidienne et le quotidien
ça peut poser un problème mais il faut à
mon avis apporter des nuances la
diversité culturelle en soi n'est pas
forcément un problème
oui on vous a entendu mais alors armand
laferrère pardonnez moi de vous mettre
une casquette de normaliens mais pour
vous est-ce que le voc isme c'est une
belle construction du récit national et
bien sûr il s'est fait pour ça l hautil
ça vient des états unis ça vient d'un
groupe
initialement identifiés au parti
démocrate qui s'est avaient été
marginalisés qui est maintenant devenu
dominant dans le parti démocrate qui est
contre l'idée des états unis qui veut
remplacer ça précisément par d'autres
identités toute façon l'être humain est
toujours tribales il ya toujours nous
contre eux la question c'est comment
définit-on le nous on peut le définir
nationalement et là c'est intéressant
parce qu'on peut mettre même nation des
gens très différents dans leur religion
dans leur origine sociale ou bien on
peut le définir wagnon plus primitives
et vous avez parlé de race tout à
l'heure tu es un mot répugnante il
faudrait il faudrait qu'on se mette tous
d'accord pour ne pas utiliser à mon sens
ce métier ce que les web met en avant
aux états unis pour démolir le ton le
récit national américain et ensuite ils
essaient de l'importer en fera
l'exporter en france et ça marche pas
très bien dieu merci mais bien sûr bien
sûr à cazeneuve pour ou contre le voc
isme totalement compte totalement
conduite alors écoutez unanimité
unanimité sur le sujet
[Musique]
alors écoutez nous en venons nous
emmenons made in france à l'heure de la
globalisation
aujourd'hui quelle pertinence y at-il à
défendent un patriotisme économique
louis gallois
moi je constate que depuis deux ans le
mot souveraineté économique n'y est plus
devenu un gros mot les gens l'utilisent
parce qu'ils sont aperçus que cette
dépendance extrême nous avions vis-à-vis
des chaînes de valeur comme on dit qui
éparpillés dans le monde avait
sur nous des conséquences extrêmement
précise on n'avait pas paracétamol on
n'avait pas de masques etc donc je crois
que
l'expérience des deux dernières années
est en train de réhabiliter l'idée de
patriotisme économique
et je pense que c'est une idée très
forte je pense je le mets d'une france
ses limites on le sait bien
mais
lisez de gratitude que je reprends je
vous reprends l'idée que l'on doit
quelque chose à son pays
je pense que c'est une chose qu'il faut
mettre dans l'esprit des français
consommateurs et dans l'esprit des
français dans les entreprises et moi je
pense que c'est un levier très fort pour
le redressement économique de notre pays
pour sa ré industrialisation et pour
cette souveraineté économique qui n'est
jamais totale un vase essayons de dodo
de hockey à votre avis c'est pas un peu
cocardier le patriotisme économique
non pas du tout je pense que enfin je
n'ai rien à retrancher ce que vient de
dire louis gallois je suis en total
accord avec la ligne vient de défendre
qu'il défend depuis très longtemps
une nation comme la france qui est une
puissance économique ne peut pas
pour politique économique et
industrielle
de poursuivre l'objectif funeste de
l'entreprise sans usine qui a été
théorisée par un grand patron il ya de
ça quelques années qui aboutit à une
désindustrialisation dans des secteurs
dans lesquels
nous étions notamment l'industrie
électronique bien positionné peut pas
non plus considérer qu'un pays qui a
depuis maintenant plusieurs décennies
fait le choix d'une énergie décarbonée
qui lui permet d'offrir à la fois
électro intensifs aux citoyens une
énergie qui compétitive doivent renoncer
pour des raisons idéologiques a terni
par exemple m en cash comme ça moi j'ai
pierrier ou dire que le patriotisme
économique quand on en parle très
concrètement ce sont des filières
d'excellence que l'on doit à tout prix
garder en faisant de paille de
l'innovation du transfert de technologie
de la montée en gamme de nos compétences
et qui implique aussi qu'on soit
dépourvu de naïveté à l'égard d'un
certain nombre de pays je pense
notamment aux états unis mais pas
simplement qu utilise dans un cadre
extraterritoriale leurs droits pour
défendre leurs intérêts de puissances on
l'a très bien vu en iran où les états
unis ont décidé de façon totalement
unilatérale de rompre un accord logis
cypihot et qu'ils avaient eux mêmes
contribué à négocier a signé en imposant
aux entreprises qui étaient dans ce pays
dans partir immédiatement pour la bonne
et simple raison qu'ils avaient décidé
de modifier leurs objectifs
diplomatiques et faisait du droit un
instrument destiné à atteindre leur but
poursuivant sur ce patriotisme
économique
la france est dans l'europe et dans le
monde ces grandes entreprises sont
mondialisés par les capitaux la matière
grise le commerce extérieur les
frontières voir les limites nécessaires
à délimiter des territoires un pays une
nation un continent dès lors qu'il
s'agit de l'économie ça contribue à un
protectionnisme est ce que c'est ça
c'est une solution pour la prospérité
armand laferrère vous qui travaillez
dans un secteur majeur de l'énergie
c'est une solution pour la prospérité
nationale relative alors ensuite les
modèles libéraux vous expliqueront que
si on libéralise tout ça il aura plus de
richesse au total c'est tout les plus ça
marche à peu près mais ça n'est pas la
question justement vous parlez
patriotisme le trio tisser savoir si mon
pays économiquement en termes d'emploi
en termes de balance extérieure en
termes de compétences s'en sort bien et
s'en sort bien forcément par rapport aux
autres c'est pour ça que l'opposition
patriotisme nationalisme ne me convainc
qu'à moitié donc oui une part de
protéger si on en fait trop et on
s'appauvrit tout le monde le sait mais
une part de protectionniste destiné à
dire de certaines compétences clés
certains emplois et les jeux veut les
garder chez moi je ferai en sorte que ça
soit le cas fait partie de cette idée
que nous appartenons tous à la même
communauté nationale avant d'être des
consommateurs cherchant à optimiser leur
bien-être qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce made in france
laeticia je trouve son bonheur j'aurai
deux remarques sur tout ce qui a été dit
d'abord je me demande s'il faut pas de
distinguer les ans les industries on
peut pas considérer que toutes les
industries soit aussi stratégique les
unes que les autres par exemple faire
fabriquer des chaussettes ou des tables
ou des haltères en chine ça me semble un
peu moins problématique que la
fabrication de masques donc je me méfie
une notion qui serait complètement
uniforme ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que je m'interroge
toujours sur ce que pensent les
entrepreneurs et j'ai parfois
l'impression qu'en politique on est très
prompte à vouloir décider d'en haut
voilà on va faire comme ça on va
privilégier tel ou tel secteur alors
qu'en fait la vie d'entrepreneur
concrètement elle est très différente
ils cherchent des débouchés et il a
surtout envie qu'on l'aide en ne
l'aidant pas trop c'est à dire en ne
l'accablons pas de procédures
administratives si possible et on ne
l'accablons pas d'impôts non plus et je
crois par foyer une dissociation quand
même dans notre pays entre ce que
peuvent dire certains hauts
fonctionnaires et certains hommes
politiques et la réalité donc moi
j'aimerais bien aussi qu'on s'intéresse
aux entrepreneurs bon alors sur cette
question-là louis gallois est-ce que
vous pensez que le patriotisme
économique aujourd'hui passe par la
réindustrialisation de la france je
pense surtout que la fin de citation de
la france passe par le patriotisme et
deux choses en janvier
ça va dans les deux sens comment voulez
que je
la réindustrialisation de la france quel
est son objectif
c'est de créer de l'emploi c'est de
créer de l'art de la science
puisque l'industrie est très liée à la
science c'est d'équilibrer les comptes
extérieurs parce que
en tant que français je me désole de
voir une balance commerciale déficitaire
de 84 milliards la balance commerciale
c'est la différence entre total et ils
sont on est très difficile télévision à
hauteur de 84 mise alors que les
allemands sont bénéficiaires à hauteur
de 200 milliards c'est bien sûr des la
comparaison avec l'allemagne peut pas
être fait tout le temps ce qui est
important pour nous c'est de moi je ne
suis pas contre les excès dans le vent
je suis contre les déficits français et
pour réduire les déficits français il
n'y a pas de miracle il faut ré
industrie et le pays parce que si un
déficit c'est parce que l'industrie
française n'est pas capable de pourvoir
à la demande française et que donc nous
importons énormément de produits parce
que dans un appareil industriel qui est
devenu trop petit pour notre pays et et
c'est ça qui est qui et qui est décisif
donc je pense que l'industrialisation
c'est une des conditions d'une certaine
autonomie de la france dans ce cas
qu'une un déficit commercial de cette
ampleur la france n'est pas un pays
autonome est ce que vous diriez bernard
cazeneuve qu'il y a un lien j'allais
dire ontologie carrément dans l'être
entre un patriotisme économique et un
patriotisme culturel voire politique est
ce que les choses sont liées comme je
crois qu'il ya un lien très fort entre
le patriotisme dans sa définition la
plus générique et le volonté des
dirigeants des citoyens d'un pays de
voir ce pays souverain et capable de
répondre à ses besoins essentiels l'on
évoqué tout à l'heure la question des
masques ou des médicaments pleine crise
sanitaire lorsque des événements de ce
type se produisent on a besoin d'avoir
les moyens d'y faire face par nous-mêmes
et est pas parce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur le rôle des entrepreneurs
regard du rôle de l'état bien entendu
que ce sont les entrepreneurs qui eux
mêmes décident en fonction de ce que de
ce qu'est leur stratégie leur sentiment
sur l'état de du marché ou sur l'état de
la compétition internationale d'investir
dans tel secteur que dans telle autre
plutôt que dans tel autre mais c'est à
l'état de décider à un moment donné
qu'en matière de politique énergétique
il doit faire des choix est ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous décidons de
maintenir ou pas une filière
électronucléaire française et qu'est ce
que nous faisons sur le secteur des
énergies renouvelables
comment est ce que nous développons
l'électromobilité s'il n'y avait pas eu
au début de la vème république un
certain nombre de responsables de l'état
pour décider qu'on lançait des grands
plans qui était destiné à garantir notre
souveraineté notre indépendance
nationale les chefs d'entreprise n'y
seraient pas parvenus et le mix d'une
volonté stratégique de l'état et d'un
dynamisme des chefs d'entreprise que
l'état doit encourager en n'en faisant
pas trop dans le champ de la
microéconomie mais en en faisant
suffisamment sur le terrain des grandes
orientations stratégiques pour permettre
à la nation d'être souveraine et de
pouvoir est-ce qu'on est assez proche ce
qu'on a on peut intégrer à ce
patriotisme ce qu'on appelle l'autonomie
stratégique les allemands parlent de
souveraineté stratégique est ce que vous
pensez armand laferrère que la notion de
puissance
il ne faut pas avoir honte de dire que
la france cherche la puissance les
sociétés qui ont voulu se départir de
cette notion toute une particularité
c'est qu'elles sont sorties de
l'histoire ou tel rêve d'en sortir là
les relations entre états ou entre
groupements d'état sont des relations
fondées sur la force et la force n'est
pas seulement la force militaire ça peut
l'être on le voit en ce moment peut-être
un peu plus qu'on avait un peu oublié
que ça pouvait l'être à ce mois là c'est
aussi le fait de disposer technologies
qui feront d'eux les autres dépendants
de vous c'est aussi là là deux des
talents qu'on arrive à développer chez
soi et pas ailleurs nous sommes dans un
monde
organisée sur les conflits réels ou
potentiels sur les rapports de force et
donc si on tient à son pays il faut
qu'ils soient forts oui comment vous
pensé justement les tissages trans
bonnart de sel ce patriotisme à
l'échelle internationale les russes
dix qui sont patriotes les chinois le 10
des nations européennes comme
l'allemagne mais en france on hésite
parce que il ya la question de la
puissance il faut fois timoré de là
dessus c'est comment vous évite à
l'échelle internationale je lui ai
france est considérée comme un pays
puisse en être une puissance moyenne
aujourd'hui après je pense qu'il faut
quand même distinguer la puissance
économique et la puissance en général ça
ne va pas forcément toujours de pair
dans la mesure où la france c'est quand
même une puissance militaire et je ne
sais pas si on a raison de se focaliser
par exemple sur le déficit commercial
donc là c'est aussi une question que
j'aurais aimé vous posez on peut avoir
un déficit commercial est en même temps
importer des produits moins chers ce qui
nous permet ensuite de canaliser et de
dépenser l'argent qu'on a pour d'autres
choses et pour la condition pas avoir
une balance de paiements négative
j'ai l'impression qu'en france il ya
quand même une autre session de la
balance commerciale excédentaire qui est
issue d'une longue tradition
intellectuelle et qui remonte au
mercantilisme au colbert mais oui mon là
dessus on sait quand même que la
création de valeur et les échanges ne
nécessite pas forcément une balance
excédentaire et on sait aussi que les
états unis ont une balance très très
déficitaire et pourtant c'est le pays le
plus puissant du monde donc c'est pour
ça que pense qu'il faut décorrélée quand
même la question de la puissance de la
question la balance les etats unis ont
une force exceptionnelle qui s'appelle
le dollar qui leur permettent d'utiliser
la planche à billets pour caricaturer de
financer lors de visites extérieures
nous nos déficits extérieurs on ne
finance pas on n'a pas les moyens de
financer
c'est à dire qu on le finance par la
dette et l'endettement de la france il
résulte de ce de ce déficit est donc si
on veut un jour s'attaquer aux déficits
bien à ceux à cette dette il va falloir
s'attaquer au déficit c'est clair donc
dès lors que ce défi que dès lors que
ces déficits commencer par la dette
quand le déficit de comprendre est
compensée par les services
tourisme et autres c'est un déficit qui
peut être accepté
selon votre votre ligne moi je crois
qu'il ya d'autres raisons qui nous
conduisent à souhaiter la
réindustrialisation de la france la rue
parce que j'ai vu les dégâts là des
adultes de la désindustrialisation les
fractures que du pays que nous
connaissons elles sont dues à la
désindustrialisation et si on veut
réduire ses fractures falloir
réindustrialiser et moi je pense je
voudrais envie au patriotisme qu'on peut
faire appel au patriotisme des chefs
d'entreprise on n'y fait pas
suffisamment appel
moi j'ai j'ai dirigé airbus qui est venu
en touriste franco allemande il ya
évidemment des intérêts espagnols
également mais j'ai vu à quel point
les allemands étaient capables de parler
patriotisme entre eux et je pense que
nous ne faisons pas suffisamment nous
sommes le un pays qui a presque honte de
cela alors que je pense qu'on peut
s'adresse aux chefs d'entreprise ce sont
des citoyens comme les autres on peut
s'adresser aux chefs d'entreprises en
leur demandant de patriotisme comme on
peut le demander d'ailleurs au au
consommateur vous savez vous savez qu'en
france maintenant on produit des gaz d
des masques
mais les usines de masques en france ce
travail pas à plein régime
95% des appels d'offres sur les masques
sont gagnés par des masques étranges et
donc
par des copeaux délais des producteurs
étrangers
pour la question est-ce que c'est pas
aussi aux entreprises françaises d'être
plus compétitives je pense je pense
surtout qu'il ya des filières que qu'on
a pris l'habitude de travailler ainsi et
qu' il n'y a pas ce réflexe je vois un
deuxième exemple les hôpitaux h f 18
milliards d'euros par an personne ne se
préoccupe de savoir si on pourrait pas
aider les industriels français en
respectant les règles européennes à
être les meilleurs dans les appels
d'offres c'est ce qu'il se passe
ailleurs on va pas et puis à côté on va
pas épuisé on va pas épuisé
bah économique fort important le
patriotisme et on va revenir si vous
voulez comme le temps passe et qu'on
arrive à la fin de cette émission on va
revenir sur la notion politique du
patriotisme
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs que le puits
sera jamais mais je souhaiterais vous
soumettre cette réflexion faut-il se
vouloir un destin de feuille morte pour
chercher à ce point le sens du vent
l'auteur s'y reconnaîtra n'est ce pas
bernard caster elle est tirée de votre
dernier ouvrage alors la question qui se
pose c'est est-ce que le patriotisme qui
est un sujet de temps l'on est
aujourd'hui concurrencée par une
civilisation de l'instantané où tout va
très vite et d'ailleurs tout s'efface
très vite comment résister à ce vertige
pour que le patriotisme ne finisse pas
comme une feuille morte
bon ça c'est une question qui mériterait
très très louis développement je pense
comme vous et c'est à dire la raison
pour laquelle j'ai j'ai écrit cette
phrase que les formes de communication
politique moderne le spontanéisme
la santana isme qui résulte de la
communication numérique
le caractère sommaire de la
communication sur les chaînes
d'information en continu fait qu'on ait
constamment dans la réaction à l'urgence
on n'est jamais sûr la réflexion
essentielle sur le déploiement d'une
réflexion longue qui touche à ce que
nous sommes fondamentalement est ce que
nous voulons faire de la nation terme
d'objectifs industriels l'objectif
environnemental
d'objectifs éducatif donc il y à une
déconnexion entre les modalités de
communication
contemporain ce qu'il implique en terme
de comportement ce qu'ils engendrent sur
le plan politique c'est à dire je dois
même très frappé de voir que la
politique ait de moins en mois un art de
la conviction
qui permet d'armes et la sincérité avec
des arguments pour essayer d'emporter la
conviction de l'autre et de ramener à
soi mais de plus en plus un exercice de
la séduction très éphémère cherche à
séduire dans l'instant à ramener à soi
par la séduction à certain nombre
d'électeurs au d'interlocuteurs mais la
séduction à des effets de court terme
alors que la conviction elle elle
s'inscrit dans le temps plus long donc
impossible de dénaturation de la
politique d'abaissement la politique
résultant des modes de communication
modernes et puis aussi d'un abaissement
du système politique français alors on
est en pleine élection présidentielle il
ya plus de partie vous a pas échappé en
tous les cas ce qui demeure sont
extraordinairement faible le débat est
d'une grande violence est
contenue est assez faible quand même
malgré tout et il n'y a pris le corps
intermédiaire puisque sur les grandes
questions sociales ya plus
d'organisations syndicales que l'on
respecte avec lesquels on négocie les
bons compromis sociaux
lorsque l'on s'adresse aux français on
s'adresse à leur instinct on ne cherche
pas à s'adresser à leur intelligence
donc tout cela ne me paraît pas de
nature à inscrire le patriotisme dans
dans
la chose politique de façon profonde
durable et convaincante est ce que vous
constatez ce décalage temps long du
patriotisme du politique en cours des
modes de vie à leur temps long de la
politique tout ce que vous dites enfin
je le partage entièrement moi je suis
atterré de voir à quel point
l'instantané a pris le dessus et la
séduction enfin vraiment
voilà je partage complètement votre
analyse mais alors sur un tout autre
plan je serai un peu plus optimiste sur
ce que moi j'appelle le patriotisme du
quotidien c'est à dire que je pense que
très souvent on est patriote sans le
savoir on est patriote parce que eh bien
on aime son quartier son village sa
ville et son pays et on y réfléchit pas
forcément c'est à dire que là on est en
train de conceptualiser un sujet que nos
concitoyens vivent dans leur chair au
quotidien donc ça ça me rend plutôt
optimiste et alors armand laferrère tan
lontan cours par rapport à la culture
par rapport à pas 3 du fait que toutes
les tentatives
faire disparaître le temps long et chou
que oui à des modes mais que les modes
ne crée pas d'identité et que on a tous
besoin d'identité et que cette identité
peut être très variable on l'a dit tout
à l'heure il ya des gens qui essaient de
se réfugier derrière une identité
drastique et le scandale absolu mais il
en faut une
et aux identités religieuses qui sont
remontés tamouls c'est alors qu'on
espérait faire disparaître à force de
distraction et que dans ce jeu d
identité qui ne disparaîtra jamais dire
attendez il ya de la place pour
l'identité nationale elle a un très
grand avantage elle ne vous oblige pas
être solidaire seulement d'une classe
sociale seulement d'une ethnie sa
demande une religion elle vous oblige à
être solidaires des gens qui vivent avec
vous c'est ce que disait sur la nation
encore une fois pas tri nations pour moi
c'est très proche ce que disait ernest
renan en 1887 sur la nation aux
richesses de la nation c'est un
référendum de tous les jours et une
identité qui est de dire je veux
défendre les intérêts de ceux des gens
avec qui je vis et des gens avec qui je
partage
l'histoire l'aquila les antennes de la
culture est une identité me semble-t-il
moins dangereuses - hostiles -
créatrice de guerre contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu croire que celle qu'on a
essayé de leur le suggérer pour la
remplacer alors louis gallois en termine
cette émission là dessus sur ce sujet
cette déconnexion entre le temps long de
la civilisation et le temps court que
nous vivons quotidiennement est ce que
c'est à cela que vous attribuez le fait
qu'on se plaint partout de l'absence du
bien commun c'est à dire que les gens
aillent à un espèce de l'égoïsme des
nations rejoint l'égoïsme des individus
et le bien commun restent en rade
l'égoïsme des nations études presque
dans leur nature il faut pas se faire
d'illusions nous sommes dans des
rapports de force
même à l'intérieur l'union européenne
nous sommes dans des rapports de force
on le sait bien et les nations vie avec
cela
en
dans un pays comme le nôtre je pense
qu'il faut être plus vigilant pour que
ce que ces rapports de force ne dégénère
pas mais moi ce qui me préoccupe le plus
est le propos de bernard cazeneuve me
conduit c'est qu'on assiste à une sorte
de défaite de la raison c'est à dire que
le raisonnement
vous avez à plessala la conviction fait
face et faire passer des convictions de
convaincre tout ça ça n'existe plus on
est dans l'instantané on est dans
l'image on est dans le dans le ressenti
quasiment dans l'émotion les gens ne
vivent plus que sur l'émotion et et je
pense que cette défaite de la raison et
les lourdes de conséquences pour
l'avenir alors abaissement de la raison
des fêtes de la pensée mais est-ce que
c'est aussi une défaite de la politique
bernard cazeneuve plus qu'à ça se
traduit par un abaissement de la
politique la politique c'est encore une
fois un art qui consiste à développer
une argumentation rationnelle pour
convaincre ce n'est pas un exercice qui
consiste
à séduire encore quand les instincts ou
fortiori en essayant de les réveiller et
nous sommes dans une période où c'est
moins le raisonnement rationnel que l'
on convoque que l' usage de la phrase
brève au service des idées courtes c'est
à dire le tweet
merci bernard cazeneuve merci madame
merci monsieur d'avoir quoi animer avec
moi cette émission je voudrais
maintenant signaler la bibliographie qui
nous a permis de la préparer et en même
temps les derniers livres qui sont parus
sur le sujet bernard cazeneuve le sens
de notre nation
vous dites pendant ce livre d'entretiens
avec françois bazin quel a été votre
exercice politique notamment sur un plan
régaliens
ministre d'intérieur premier ministre
c'est un vous l'avez écrit parce que
vous sentiez un danger ou voix c'était
parce que vous vouliez marqué une étape
dont je les écris simplement prendre
compte d'une expérience qui avait été la
mienne
pour
m'inquiéter du fait qu'à salon de
référence auxquelles je crois qu'ils
sont aspirés par mon attachement au
gaullisme moment des zizou vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure s'effacer s'étiole
merci alors laetitia strauss bonnart de
la france ce pays que l'on croyait
connaître c'est à dire que vous avez
découvert la france en écrivant ce livre
non je vous propose de la redécouvrir
avec moi mais plus sérieusement c'est un
c'est un livre qui analyse la situation
politique sociale économique de la
france et qu'ils essaient d'expliquer
pourquoi nous avons tant de mal dans
certains domaines mais aussi pourquoi
nous sommes un grand pays mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez découvert essentiellement
c'est à dire quelque chose que vous
n'attendiez pas
je pense que j'ai découvert à quel point
j'aimais la france et surtout je parlais
du positif je ne m'attendais pas en fait
à dire autant de choses positives sur la
france vit pourtant je les fais merci il
faut il faut le faire sans gêne
d'ailleurs vous avez tout à fait raison
alors armand laferrère vous avez écrit
cet ouvrage avec moshe sebag l'éternité
des juifs dans vous pensez qu'il y à une
éternité de cette culture de cette
civilisation
cette religion en tout cas il y a une
durée exceptionnelle par rapport à celle
de la plupart des civilisations et des
civilisations comme la nôtre la
française ou d'autres qui sont moins
anciennes et dit se demandent si elles
ne sont pas en train de finir parce que
soyons honnêtes c'est ça la source de
l'emploi ce qui cause une partie des
problèmes que nous voyons aujourd'hui ne
peuvent rien perdre à regarder comment
un autre pub dans des conditions bien
pires parce qu'on se plaint de
l'immigration mais quand on est plus
qu'un peuple minoritaire c'est encore
plus difficile de survivre quand on a
une minorité t-il aussi en son sein a
quand même réussi à tenir beaucoup plus
longtemps que à peu près toutes les
autres civilisations plus de la terre à
part quelques unes très gros sur les
deux territoires comme la chine ou la
perse en somme c'est un éloge du temps
long de cette civilisation d'un éloge du
peuple juif à travers lui des
civilisations qui savent dur et oui car
je voudrais rappeler un ouvrage de jean
daniel av benoît cana bus
réconcilier la france une histoire vécue
de la nation effectivement on découvre
jean daniel et la question de la nation
et on s'aperçoit que finalement il était
taraudée par cette question de la nation
et qu'ils s'inquiétaient qu'elle pouvait
se défaire et se déconstruire et ce
livre est très intéressant et ce qui est
plus intéressant dans ce type notamment
ces sont les réflexions sur la nation de
jean daniel il ya de cela 40 à 50 on est
l'écho de ses réflexions dans
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui c'est un très
beau livre merci je voudrais signaler
patrice guillamot la nation pour une
définition philosophique
alors ce livre est extrêmement
intéressant parce qu'ils montrent un
récit national j'allais dire de l'autre
côté c'est à dire du côté
religieux du côté de pensée politique
meubles qu'on peut qualifier à la droite
de la droite et est intéressant d'en
prendre connaissance pour voir la
commande de récits nationaux peuvent
aujourd'hui se confronter et donc il
faut en prendre connaissance pour
comprendre d'ailleurs le soubassement de
certaines pensées extrême en politique
je voudrais vous remercier madame nous
remercier monsieur d'avoir participé à
cette émission et avant de nous quitter
je vous laisse avec cette remarque
d'ernest renan
non ce n'est pas la terre plus que la
race qui fait une nation l'homme fournit
l'âme
[Musique]